Democrats complained they were being
shut out from classified intelligence
briefings they were ultimately included
after today's briefings led by top
intelligence justice and FBI officials
regarding president Trump's allegations
the FBI inserted a spy into his campaign
at least one Democratic lawmaker wasn't
convinced nothing we heard today has
changed our view that there is no
evidence to support any allegation that
the FBI were any intelligence agency
placed a spy in the Trump campaign or
otherwise failed to follow appropriate
procedures and protocols the initial
plan was to meet with House Republican
chairman Devin Nunez and trey Gowdy but
the White House added Democrats and the
top congressional and Intelligence
Committee leaders in a brief statement
Speaker Paul Ryan defended the efforts
of House lawmakers conducting oversight
of the executive branch saying he looked
forward to the Intelligence Committee
promptly completing its work since
they're now getting the cooperation they
need on Fox and Friends President Trump
was asked about an attack from former
FBI director James Comey who tweeted
yesterday facts matter
the FBI's use of confidential human
sources the actual term is tightly
regulated and essential to protecting
the country the firing of James Comey is
going to go down as a very good thing
FBI is great I know so many people in
the FBI the FBI is a fantastic
institution but some of the people at
the top were rotten apples James Comey
was one of them I've done a great
service for this country by getting rid
of them by firing South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham said he has serious
questions about the actions of the Obama
Justice Department during the 2016
campaign
the president also made reference to
former DNI James clapper on Twitter
clapper has now admitted that there was
spying in my campaign large dollars were
paid to the spy far beyond normal
starting to look like one of the biggest
political scandals in US history spy
gate a terrible thing even though there
was an effort to include Democrats their
leaders suggested the meetings should
have been canceled when one party
representative Nunez who so clearly
wants to distort national security
information for partisan purposes asks
for a solitary briefing there shouldn't
be a briefing at all it appears that
it's a meeting that could be sharing
information that somebody's
interpretation of could possibly be
helpful to the president's defense late
today former DNI clapper responded to
the president accusing him of spinning
and distorting what clapper said clapper
says he took a version to the word spy
and called it the most benign version of
information gathering saying they were
trying to figure out if the Russians
were attempting to infiltrate the Trump
campaign